soyou're yes yeah yes it's just fun to
say is is it like in your contract now
that you have to have the best character
names yes like you're not allowed to
have any white character names no they
just find away their selves to me I'm
here for you
all the characters with the great names
who is yes in the world of Roth breaks
the internet yes is the head algorithm
of a trend making website called
BuzzFeed and so if it's now
yes knows about it and she's already
told the world yes and she has an eye
for videos to go viral actors always say
the best part of voice acting is that
they get to roll up without being done
in gesture so that's are you like that
too I can't imagine that you're going in
there every day just being like in your
pajamas and going to do voice recording
or is that really the way it is yeah I'm
very comfortable yes she does the work
for me that's right the animators I
remember being in high school the first
time I ever used Google I was like this
is wild like I can look for anything do
you remember where you were what you
were doing the first time you realize
the internet was like a thing I was in
my room sleep and my um little cousin at
the time his mom she's very technical
and she works for the government and she
this is like when laptops first came out
and so she was in my room on my old
dinosaur computer that I just knew how
to open emails that was it and I just
heard some kids and I was like what is
that and she's like oh girl it's the
internet I was like what is the internet
and then three hours later when she
signed on okay you know I still didn't
get it until I was able because I was
broke back then I couldn't afford the
internet so eventually when it became
when I had to have it you know more I
busier I got and it was like okay this
is the world of everything food yeah
well yes is like the ultimate taste
maker
how good are you at keeping up with
trends and memes like knowing what's
going on online and Twitter and
Instagram
well they make it very easy for you I
have to do a scroll that's all you have
to do to find out basically world news
you just get on the internet social
media will tell you everything so you
just scroll it's not how hard we're
actually becoming very lazy thank you
thank you yes well whole thing like you
can do anything when you first saw when
you first saw the movie do you think wow
this is kind of how I envision what the
internet would be like this major
metropolis all these different alleyways
to go down was that was it did it strike
you as being kind of truthful in a way
yeah it actually gave me a bit of calm
you know now I know what the internet
looks like even though we know it's not
real but in my mind I'm just like okay
kind of what I thought what would you
say is like the most ridiculous thing
that you've ever found and purchased
online given that you can go and get
anything in the whole world online now
ah the most ridiculous thing that I've
got I wouldn't say ridiculous
I just purchased this thing called the
almond cow this is my I'm like mmm it
just makes nut milk
oh so you can put any and it's called
the almond cow and you just put you put
almonds yeah yeah if you any kind of nut
milk cashew milk almond milk pecan mill
know it's probably almond cap now my
interest is piqued and now it's gonna go
viral that's held in a network that's
how it works that's how it works
well yeah thank you so much for your
time movie was so fun yeah yeah I'm
gonna get out